hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play surgeon
simulator 2013 we need to give this
patient a new heart can we do it well
with my skill and determination I am
certain that we can so let's take a look
at this patient hmm let's see here oh
yes okay good
um nurse twenty-seven cc's of Hydra
morgue of floor bits lemon please huh
here's the other heart yep just where I
expected it to be and drag that into
place just toss it oh no where's the
heart go where's the heart go where my
heart no where to go okay um people all
notice people won't notice because this
guy is now gonna have I'm on a crazy
base oh god oh god what am i doing
people are gonna realize that I'm a
fraud I got a fraud I'm not a fraud you
bastard you think you know the pressures
of a doctor you think I know I know I've
gotta kill you
I don't even know what tool this is but
I'm gonna use it to the best of my
ability the thoracic cavity into the
lungs there EULA's the nipples the penis
the vagina that's all I know
that's all I'm ever gonna know well with
my skill and determination I am certain
that we can know what is vast
Wilfred war - nose was fast